y una endoscopia del tracto
gastrointestinal superior también
denominada esófago gastroduodenales
copia o eje de es un procedimiento que
le permite al médico visualizar las
paredes mucosas de la parte superior del
tracto gastrointestinal esto incluye el
esófago estómago y duodeno
la endoscopía superior se utiliza para
evaluar los síntomas de un dolor
abdominal superior persistente náusea
vómito sangrado o dificultad en la
deglución
puede detectar de forma precisa la
inflamación la infección los tumores las
úlceras y otros problemas que se puedan
presentar el procedimiento se realiza
utilizando un endoscopio que es un tubo
flexible delgado y largo con una luz de
una cámara de vídeo diminuta en el
extremo la cámara transmite la imagen a
un monitor antes de someterse a la
endoscopia se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y se le ofrecerán
medicamentos para el dolor y un sedante
se controlarán la presión sanguínea el
pulso del nivel de oxígeno en la sangre
durante el procedimiento el médico le
aplicará anestesia local en la garganta
con un atomizador o le pedirá que se
haga gárgaras con un anestésico para
adormecer la zona se le pedirá que se
recueste sobre el lado izquierdo se le
colocará una boquilla de apoyo en la
boca en algunos casos se le
proporcionará oxígeno adicional mediante
una cánula nasal las endoscopias
superiores que no presentan
complicaciones tardan entre 10 y 20
minutos
el médico insertará cuidadosamente el
endoscopio por la boca y luego lo movera
lenta y cuidadosamente hacia el esófago
hasta que llegue al estómago
y finalmente al duodeno no debería
sentir dolor mientras esto sucede el
médico puede introducir periódicamente
una cantidad pequeña de aire para
aplanar las paredes mucosas y mejorar la
visibilidad si el médico quiere obtener
muestra de tejido para analizarla
después lo podrá hacer con el endoscopio
una biopsia ayudará a distinguir entre
los tejidos cancerosos y los benignos
también se utiliza para detectar la
helicobacter pilori la bacteria que
puede ocasionar la formación de úlceras
el médico también puede utilizar el
endoscopio para tratar un problema como
por ejemplo una úlcera sangrante o
ensanchar un estrechamiento del esófago
o el estómago después del procedimiento
se lo controlará hasta que desaparezcan
los efectos del medicamento es posible
que le duela la garganta y que la sienta
un poco hinchada deberá contar con
alguien que lo lleve a su hogar más
tarde